is that  it can't be  it is  just start at the beginning  we landed on mars  it looked wrong  like we were in a dream  and rewarded sabadoon's ship  the wicked thing the lure yeah  we wanted to find her  try to gain the upper hand  but she was baiting us  what happened next my ghost brought me  back  we kept going  [Music]  she knew we would  and that's when you saw the night  i'll never forget  they refuse to die  here just like us  [Music]  and you're sure you're absolutely sure  it was light salvathun's illusions can  fool the senses no  i know what i saw  this is real what made you push forward  we needed to know what that thing was  we couldn't stop  what has she done  [Music]  you